Let's go to the phone lines at six one seven
eight three zero.
Forty seven fifty.
We will start with our caller from the two
zero one area code.
And it might take just a moment to make sure
that the caller can hear me and that I can
hear the caller.
Caller from two a one.
Can you hear me?
You're on right now.
Yeah, hi.
Can you hear me?
I can't.
How are you?
Who's this?
Hi, I'm Joshua, I'm from New Jersey.
Great.
What's on your mind today?
Yeah.
So my question.
It's it's about the pandemic that's going
on.
Yes.
So obviously, the cone of our stats have recently
surpassed one hundred 160000 thousand, which,
if you do the math, is more than 50 911.
Yes.
And obviously, besides the deaths, the pandemic
has cost people's jobs and their houses and
so much more.
Yet despite all of that, Republicans and their
voters have remained firmly ignorant of the
severity of this pandemic.
So with all of that in mind, my question is
just how much worse do you think this pandemic
has to get for Republicans and their voters
to finally realize the sheer gravity of the
situation and thereby commit to substantial
action?
I believe, you know, is shockingly mask wearing
at the individual level to maybe even Republicans
like passing actual relief bills.
I believe that it will not get that bad enough
for them while Donald Trump is still president.
If he loses in November.
And so what I mean by that is if Biden wins
in November.
It will still not be bad enough at that point
for Republicans to say, you know, our approach
was not the right one when you look at just
about every other country, with some few exceptions.
I just don't think it will get that bad because
it's a combination of ignorance, denial, this
feeling of inevitability that like, listen,
this is what it is.
We just we can't stop our lives.
When, of course, as you're pointing out, a
lot of those hundred and almost hundred and
seventy thousand deaths.
Now, those many of those were optional and
they came from not taking the right measures.
I don't think we're going to get there.
I think that it's going to time out now.
If Biden doesn't win and Trump gets another
four years, I think that he's going to be
saved by the bell anyway.
Because before Republicans say it's now bad
enough that we need to do more, we'll have
a vaccine, Dezso.
So I think that they will not get to the point
where Republicans say, well, we got it wrong.
We've got to do a rethink.
Yeah, yeah, oh, yeah, I definitely agree.
I was on the pessimistic side myself that
Republicans would just commit to their ignorance.
Yeah, and yeah, I mean, it's just so frustrating
because, well, ethnically, I'm from South
Korea and I watch the Korean news every night.
And it's we're an absolute embarrassment.
Yeah.
The United States, like, um, like the South
Korean news outlets, like they bring up entire
segments where they basically just roast the
United States for 30 minutes plus like they'll
bring up clips of, like the adults having
temper tantrums about wearing masks.
They'll bring up like clips of Trump saying
to slow down testing.
Yeah, we're an absolute embarrassment.
It's so frustrating that not only is the man
in the White House like denying the significance
of this problem, but everyone around him is
also committing to ignorance.
Yeah.
When I said that the U.S. is a laughing stock.
It was not a metaphor.
It was.
I mean, literally, the world is in shock at
how poorly we are dealing with this.
And, you know, the problem with it, with all
of it is the people who most need to hear
it don't care that South Korea and France,
France and the Netherlands, that they're all
laughing at us because they're like, look,
we do what we do.
We don't care about, you know, CESI Europeans
or people in Asia or halfway across.
They just don't care.
So it's like there's no reaching them, sadly.
But it is what it is.
And hopefully we can remove Trump sooner than
later.
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
It's just so frustrating.
All right.
Thanks, David.
Thank you.
I appreciate the phone call.
Great to hear from you.